well for two years they told you that
Robert Muller was a moral hero
questioning any part of his
investigation amounted to a betrayal of
this country firing him would be treason
the only real question about Robert
Muller was where in the National Mall to
put his statue everyone agreed it should
be at least as big as Lincoln's and then
on Sunday Muller dashed their dreams
after conducting the most thorough
investigation in recent American history
he concluded there was no collusion
between the Trump campaign and the
government of Russia for the left this
was disastrous news as was the political
equivalent of a stock market crash
literally ratings on CNN MSNBC plummeted
immediately in some cases by more than
50%
they promised our audience a conspiracy
when the conspiracy evaporated so did
their viewers democratic officeholders
faced a similar problem what do you say
to the mob on Twitter that secretly
believes that Trump speaks Russian tough
questions they decided to say nothing
just pretend that nothing has changed
watch senator cory booker explained that
indeed the conspiracy continues complex
and diabolical as ever only now the
newly installed attorney general is part
of the conspiracy to bob miller did not
find a chargeable collusion conspiracy
here's what how you described it as
recently as as 2017 there continues to
seem to be smoke that might result in an
actual fire in other words real
collusion going on between us and the
soviet union real collusion going on you
said do you now have to revise that to
say not chargeable collusion again would
I have a attorney general who in my
opinion is suspect filtering a report
that I have not seen I'm not willing to
conclude anything yet yeah they don't
Joyce bar congressman Eric swallow is
less creative than that swallow doesn't
have a clever new theory about Russia
really about anything he likes his old
theories just fine they've worked for
him he doesn't want to hear about any of
your evidence or facts
he likes the world as it was last week
don't bother arguing with him if you
don't like it you can go ahead and sue I
stand by what I said about
of course if you had to pop with that
he's consuming and I promise you I would
win go ahead and sue over on Sina and
there was near panic at the news let's
say you'd spent decades claiming to be
the most trusted name in news and then
it turned out you were way less reliable
than Alex Jones who by the way you'd
single-handedly forced off the air
hilariously on the grounds he was too
inaccurate to be heard by the American
public
you'd be pretty worried all of a sudden
you wouldn't want to apologize because
that would be the same as acknowledging
your fraud so you just keep lying
watch the governor's brother do just
that paralyzed you guys yes this network
what if I done I've tortured this man
for two years with collusion and
nobody's apologist of all their before
we talk about obstruct here was
apologize for the overreaction solution
not a chance of course you're not not a
chance about being fair no apologize
never here's my K never never I didn't
do anything wrong
these questions are real i I didn't even
be regarded as such apologize
apologizing never even occurred to Don
Lemon mr. lemon is a very busy man he
didn't have time to read the entire
summary of the mohel report he's got
people for that but from the back of his
may Bach heading home from dinner he
glanced his device and saw a line from
it posted on Instagram that was enough
Don Lemon knows what he knows bar quotes
him saying while this report does not
conclude that the president committed a
crime it also does not exonerate him
crime it also does not exonerate him and
it also does not exonerate him and it
also does not exonerate him it also does
not exonerate him well it may be true
but this point Donald Trump isn't really
the one who needs to be exonerated